voyageurs lésés ont des recours.
Marie-Michelle Lauzon
nous en donne un aperçu.
- Chaos dans la plupart des
aéroports à travers le monde,
Montréal ne fait pas exception.
Jacob Charbonneau a fondé
l'entreprise Vol en retard
il y a six ans pour accompagner
les voyageurs.
Vous êtes occupé?
- Oui, on est très occupés...
- Le téléphone ne dérougit pas.
JACOB CHARBONNEAU, pdg,
Vol en retard
- On a des gens qui
nous appellent en pleurs,
parce qu'ils sont dans
des situations pas peseseses.
Plusieurs cas où est-ce qu'on
entend des choses qu'on devrait
pas entendre. Souvent, bien,
justement, les passagers ne sont
pas experts nécessairement
de leurs droits.
- En effet, les passagers ont
des droits, et les compagnies
aérionononont des obligations
envers ceux-ci en cas de retard
ou d'annulation de vol.
- Les passagers devraient être
informés à toutes les 30 minutes
lors d'un retard de vol sur
la situation et quand est-ce
que... la solution va arriver
ou le prochain vol.
- Chaque 30 minutes?
- Oui! Donc, on voit pas ça
présentement, c'est plutôt
l'inverse, les passagers qui
courent après l'inioioioion.
Pour les valises, il y a des
normes de protection, notamment,
il y a des indemnisations
jusqu'a 2400 $. Et il y a aussi
un délai très court, donc on a
21 jours pour faire la demande.
- Différentes options s'offrent
aux voyageurs pour les protéger.
La Cdedededes voyageurs,
le Règlement de protection
des passagers aériens,
la Convention de Montréal,
la Convention de Varsovie,
le Règlement européen 261-2004
et le Département de transport
Américain, communément appelé
le DOT.
CHARLES TANGUAY, Office de
la protection du consommateur
- Il y a également le fonds
d'indemnisation des clients des
agents de voyages.usususus avez
fait affaire avec un agent
de voyage qui est titulaire d'un
permis du Québec, le fonds peut
vous indemniser en cas de défaut
d'un des fournisseurs, et ça,
c'est très intéressant
parce qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir recours au tribunal.
SYLVIE DE BELLEFEUILLE,
avocate Option consommateurs
- Dans certains cas, il peut
y avoir des règles européennes
qui, parfois, sont peut-être
plus avantageuses ou pas, c'est
toujours du cas par cas, alors
ça vaut la peine de s'informer.
- Les experts recommandent
également de prendre une
assurance voyage personnelle.
Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon,
Radio-Canada, Montréal